foreign
we'll call the fiscal committee meeting
to order for May 19th
and acknowledge that we'll have
uh one Senator missing and Senate and
representative Edwards will be arriving
so any
thing on I'll entertain a motion to
adopt the minutes from April 21st
something
motion by Senator gray second by
Senator Rosenwald to adopt the minutes
as written any any further questions or
suggestions seeing Nani ready for the
question all in favor say aye aye oppose
no
that the minutes are adopted moving on
to Tab 3
I will note that we have
consent calendar that goes from Tab 3
through tab 7.
and I've got request to remove
six of the items from consent
23 under Tab 3
item 23144 request by representative
Edwards will be arriving later
under Tab 5 23 153 representative erf
under tab 6
23146 requests from the Senate
and 23 152
senator from the Senate and from
representative Edwards
23 169 Senator Rosenwald wanted removed
and
23155 against Senator Edwards are there
if not I'll entertain a motion to adopt
the second adopt the consent calendar
motion by uh Senator gray second by
Senator Bradley to an is to adopt the
consent calendar with the notable
exceptions any further discussion
seeing none are you ready for the
question all in favor say aye aye
opposed no
consent calendar with the above
mentioned exceptions is adopted we won't
come yet to 23 144 until uh
representative Edwards arrives
but we'll go to the next item on the
list
foreign
excuse me
and that was Health and Human uh Health
representative Earth is recognized for
questions
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
White my question really is could you
just give us
a little more in-depth explanation of
what this is all about thank you
of course uh good morning Nathan white
Chief Financial Officer with the
Department of Health and Human Services
um this uh to representative Earth's
point this item is certainly a little
unique I don't think this has happened
certainly in recent memory
what we're doing here there there's two
key purposes behind this item um the
first is to establish a new accounting
unit uh to ensure that the the dish
recruitments and red distributions are
done in a transparent way so that's one
action within this item the other key
component of this is authority to accept
and expend those redistributions and so
the department contracts with an
independent third-party auditor that
looks at the dis at the dish
distributions
and we've been working with with that
auditor and this accounting unit would
allow us to collect the funds and reduce
from certain hospitals and redistribute
to other hospitals we have not been able
to do this because of ongoing federal
and state litigation for some time and
the amounts that you see represented
here these are the audits from 2011
through 2017.
um the 2018 and 2000 19 audits are still
currently underway and being finalized
and you typically see about a three-year
delay with the audit process due to a
variety of procedures the audits are
done again by a third party to come up
with those determinations and they're
done in accordance with CMS regulations
um and I will stop there for further
questions
so it's basically moving money
essentially from One hospital to another
hospital is that kind of what's going on
that is correct so it's the Auditors
looked at the distribution amounts that
were made to each of the hospitals and
um through that process determinations
have been made that funds need to be
redistributed uh to the other hospitals
some were overpaid somewhere underpaid
uh based on based on the criteria I know
that there was a question that came in
relative to whether we could identify
the specific amounts that went from
which hospital to the other hospital I'm
still waiting to hear back from legal on
a final determination relative to what
would be considered proprietary
financial information and what could be
shared publicly essentially what would
be subject to right to know
so essentially there's no new money here
this is basically as redistributing
those funds those federal funds
precisely this is a net zero impact but
we just need the authority to accept
those dollars and and to pay those
dollars out thank you very much of
course
Senator Rosenwald for a question
good morning Nathan so are we going to
be
what we were doing prior to the dish
settlement or are we going to be
redistributing
in accordance with the dish settlement
so it was a very complicated history
here behind all of this and excellent
and Meredith Toulouse has lived and
experienced this entire history and
she's here to dive right into the
I didn't I didn't actually have to live
through the whole history but I've been
here for part of it and I can tell you
that what we have done is
each year we've made payments in
accordance with the settlements
but those payments are still based on
interim data
so every year there's a every year that
we've made a payment there's been a
subsequent dish audit
and so these redistributions are to come
into compliance with the amounts of
uncompensated care based on that audited
amount
okay
Senator dallasandro so it's a true up
it's a true up exactly yes we make the
payments in the year based on the
settlement that's in place at the time
and then we have to True up based on the
actual amounts once the audit is
complete it's nice to see you Meredith
very nice to see you Senator thank you
I guess the questions arose we've never
seen on this on the agenda before
correct this is the first time we're
doing a redistribution
thank you
and
okay motion to approve the item
by
Senator gray second by Senator Bradley
further discussion any any further
questions we'll come back to you as
no we haven't we haven't no he wasn't
can ask a question on this one
you have a question on this this item
yeah go ahead I can't find my note I did
I did think I had a question but go
ahead all right
all in favor say aye aye opposed no now
we'll go to the item that I that Senator
Edwards had removed in tab three
and that was
144. 144. it's again Health and Human
Services
Senator Edwards is recognized for a
question
a representative Edwards uh thank you I
was a little reluctant to speak up there
but uh I um thank you Mr chair the uh
the school children of uh of Auburn
Village School say hello and send their
warm greetings uh thank you for allowing
me to be a little bit late to this
um I I understand and support what we're
trying to do with the with this item
um uh the
1.125 million uh is is uh is good to
build out the system of care what I
think we need to start knowing though is
when these kinds of transfers or or or
or new expenditures have an impact or
are perceived to potentially have an
impact on the ER boarding crisis
um I I'd like to know it I mean in
theory every time we improve the system
of care I think we can assume that
there's some inter if you know maybe
indirect uh benefit to eliminating the
ER boarding problem but what I would
appreciate is if we could get as much as
you can sort of a direct connection
between the new spend and the reduction
in that the number of people being
boarded and and I'm I'm I'm thinking
that that's particularly ripe and
important for us
because of the court order to say we
have to fix this in a year right and so
we need to know where we're at and what
we're doing and what the potential
impact may be to be able to help you so
so so today on this particular item are
you able to say anything that you're
confident in in terms of projecting a
more direct impact on the ER boarding
problem
thank you
thank you representative Edwards Marissa
hen associate commissioner at DHHS and
um welcome the opportunity to reflect on
that for a moment
um you know first I think this item
which is dealing with our children's
system of care so looking at getting
kids into the right level of care to
meet their behavioral health needs
whether those are able to be served in
the community or require a more
intensive level of treatment in a
residential setting or perhaps even in
an acute psychiatric setting that's what
the department is focused on as a whole
and so I think here when we recognized
um when the when the residential system
was launched in 2021 we didn't know
exactly what the level of need would be
we didn't know through those contracts
whether we would have enough beds at the
varying levels of the Continuum and so
what this item does is allows us to
um to transfer funds not in any way to
the harm of another program but to
transfer for funds to help provide that
level of care for kids who need it
within our residential treatment system
at the same time I do want to note that
it doesn't in no way harm any of the
transitional housing type settings from
which the month the funds are
transferred those will continue those
those housing bridge and other vouchers
will continue this just allows us to put
funds where we need them right now to
the question of boarding getting people
to the level of care that they need is
part of the whole prevention of
emergency department boarding so when we
can serve people's needs ideally in the
community
in through working with schools working
with families working with Community
providers that's the best level of
prevention but we know that at times
people do have episodes whether it's in
the context of a crisis or a um or or a
situation escalating for another reason
where they need that more intensive care
ideally we want to avoid having to go
through the emergency department at all
the emergency department is not the
ideal place to be managing those
conditions and that is what this will
allow us to do in part is to continue
identifying screening in a standardized
way those youth but really we're doing
it for the population as a whole who who
may require care in a therapeutically
appropriate setting other than the
emergency department I'll just note um
finally and what's you know welcome any
follow-up questions uh
we just about 15 minutes ago announced
as a department
um a bold Vision called Mission zero
which is
um Our intention we've been working on
this for months it is connected and
aligned with the 10-year mental health
plan but our aspiration our commitment
to achieving a zero wait list
um in the next two years
um and so that today is actually a
pretty important day and I appreciate
your asking the question so that I could
so so to be clear this zero wait list
you're specifically talking about the
zero wait list for the ER or for
services to prevent somebody from going
to the ER because we have all kinds of
wait lists and DHHS right it's really a
not having people boarding in the
emergency department the term we use
when people are waiting for more acute
Services be it residential inpatient
psychiatric or otherwise in the
emergency department setting well so so
what I heard from your answer is that at
this point you think this item is going
to help create indirectly the capacity
necessary to facilitate the reduction of
er boarding but that there's not been
any analysis uh just specifically to
figure out how to Target this money with
the direct objective of reducing the ER
boarding you you you is if that's a not
a fair summary let me know but but the
but to go on
um you you just mentioned getting a zero
wait list in two years I think the court
orders is one year so we have a a bit of
a challenge in terms of timing are you
are you all able to accelerate and meet
the court order
um I can't speak to issues related to
litigation but what I will say is that
there are many things that will be
implemented even in the next few months
and we're continuing to review the court
order and the implications of that for
our work all right thank you Mr chair
thank you Mr chairman so the department
is
asking us in Senate Finance for to
extend the deadline for spending six
million dollars of housing
but also to
appropriate another 11 and a half
million dollars of system of care funds
does this million dollars affect either
of those two tasks that's a great
question so this funding will actually
um cover the increased level of
residential needs
um in the current biennium whereas the
funding you're you're referring to which
includes uh the possibility of increased
rates for residential care to meet you
know what we have learned is the
requirements under our current
um Workforce needs and complexities that
would be for the next biennium so they
they are related but this is really
covering the the current period the
current time frame and and just the
housing I mean you're transferring money
out of housing that you've asked us to
extend the deadline does that mean it
won't be six million dollars of housing
where
no the those those funds are separate um
what one of the challenges that we've
had is the I believe the rental vacancy
rate in New Hampshire is less than one
percent
um so those funds have not been able to
be utilized which is why they're
available here
um based on current projected spend they
won't be used this year These funds are
foreign
representative Irv thank you Mr chair
thank you
so I come from a rural area and I just
like to understand specifically how this
might actually work out and I'll
acknowledge up front my wife happens to
be an ENT so that's where I get this
knowledge from
um they have mental crisis occasionally
oftentimes in children but also adults
and their natural what they all they can
do is basically transport to the
hospital typically to Concord Hospital
but off also the Manchester hospitals so
in that instance how would this
be handled so that they didn't wind up
getting admitted to the hospital it's a
great question so I think one of the
um one of the elements we've been
working on as part of our tenure Mental
Health Plan has been building out a
comprehensive crisis system you're
probably familiar with the 988 phone
line for people to call as well as the
mobile crisis teams that now can be
deployed working hand in hand with First
Responders to help meet people's needs
in the community often de-escalating
them on the spot as opposed to even
having to bring them to an emergency
setting we're also building out crisis
stabilization which is the place to go
um besides the Ed as a way for people to
get care they need and oftentimes move
on from there at any one of those levels
in the community it may be identified
and we now have the Partnerships and the
assessments and the support that in fact
a youth because what we're talking about
here is our residential treatment system
which is for young people
may have clinical needs that uh that
require a stay of a matter of weeks in a
therapeutic residential setting but they
don't necessarily need to go through
emergency or Hospital settings and so
that's where that opportunity to divert
and to meet their needs would lie
follow-up okay so I think perhaps either
I'm not explaining my question
the issue I think is you have a service
this isn't where
they have no knowledge of anything you
just mentioned and and while I am
familiar with that with the things you
just mentioned I'm not the person that's
helping our Ambulance Service learn
about them so the reality is what
happens oh and I don't think anybody in
where I shouldn't say anybody but most
people would probably not be aware of
any of those Services you just mentioned
and know to dial whatever they would
call the ambulance typically they might
even call the police
police might be the first on seeing them
the analysis show up and they're all
they can all they know to do I don't
mean to say all they can do in terms of
what's offered but all they're aware to
do is to transport to the hospital so
how is that situation going to be
resolved are you going to do things with
the hospitals or you're going to do
things with training for the the smaller
departments across the state or what
we're doing all of the above and I think
this is um the Beauty and the challenge
of having something that is virtually
brand new um all rolled out within the
past year year and a half is that it
takes time um we have had
um incredible levels of consultation at
all levels of municipal government
stakeholders people with lived
experience mental health provider but we
have more to do and actually with the
support of fiscal we're launching a
Communications campaign to do just that
to make people aware of the resources
and places to call obviously if
someone's an imminent risk of harm we
want people to call 9-1-1 we don't want
people to hesitate to do that we just
want to expand the toolbox to provide
other options so appreciate your
um the personal experience you're
bringing to this we have much more work
to do but part of it is just the
inherent newness of the systems we're
building
so is there any thought to working with
the hospitals as well so even if
everything falls apart as far as before
that point so they get to the hospital
to interdict at that point is there any
plan to try to coordinate that
that is happening to an extent in a
number of Hospital settings or Community
Mental Health Centers partner with many
hospitals in a number of regions it's
there's no region that is a cookie
cutter you know it's different in every
place where we're identifying youth that
can be or adults for that reason who can
be discharged with Supportive Services
in the community that that happens all
the time
um and in fact there's even efforts um
you know I haven't mentioned this
explicitly but you know within our
residential treatment system which is
now allowing people to go who are who
otherwise had to go through dcyf
previously had to have an actual founded
allegation of abuse or neglect to access
services without not only not having to
go to the hospital or having to stay in
the hospital but without without having
to go through the court system which is
further questions on
item number
23 144. I move the item sir all right
representative Edwards moves the item
Senator Rosenwald seconds is there any
further discussion on FIS 23144 seeing
none are you ready for the question all
uh thank you Mr chair
um uh I understand that this is uh this
is probably a good item and I'm I'm
going to vote for it I just would like
to know a little bit uh more about some
detail that's not included in the
write-up
um this is uh this is retroactive money
it it says uh or a retroactive spending
because of an oversight and getting it
spent I think but in any case it's a
it's a good it's a good spend and it's
supposed to go to support services to
eligible infants toddlers birth through
two years who demonstrated developmental
delay and good with all of that I just
um
with 1.2 million dollars are you able oh
hi Miss Hardy how are you
good morning uh I I'm just I'm just
curious if we can be a little bit more
specific about who these checks will go
to what kind of provider in a specific
description as possible because I I I
don't resist this I just want to be able
to help communicate that this is going
to happen sure um good morning I'm
Melissa Hardy I'm the division director
for long-term supports and services so
there's three contractors that are
involved in this item one is Mason
Incorporated which is about 250 000 for
the development and implementation of a
public awareness campaign for early
supports and services which is currently
um already out there and worked on it
and approved by the governor so that is
out there for early support Outreach
we also have the parent information
center for about ninety three thousand
dollars to develop and Implement early
supports and services educational
surrogate parent program which is used
for
um a lot of dcyf children whose family
cannot be found to give consent for
early intervention services
and
sure the parent information center
and then finally about two uh 200 000
for a centria community services
um and that's for the translation of
documents into different languages so
that families who um English is not
their primary language can have
documents translated in their language
for understanding
follow-up
okay so that's about half of the 1.2
million those three items what what what
what about the other half
because because I'm reading that we're
we're dealing with
um
1.218 million and 250 250 and 93 is is
less than 600 000 so I'm just curious
about the rest of it it so this is a the
reason why you're not seeing any
additional dollars here is the original
requested action was for the 1.2 million
dollars and that that was from from the
year prior
this this item here
um the original Grant ended September
30th of of 2022 and so what Melissa's
referring to is the new price
limitations that are associated with it
with the dollars after the extension
in September of 2022 not prior to that
because the original item if you turn to
pay well to to the original item this
this was approved in September 22 this
was back in September of 2021 so those
other dollars were previously spent
within that Grant period these are the
dollars after the these are the dollars
well
look at page one of that request and
you'll see the other items that add up
to the 1.2
yes sir my curiosity was
um after we approved this what entities
may be expecting to be paid some money
that that would not be paid if we did
not approve this and and and Miss Hardy
gave me a great explanation on about
half of it and I I can go offline to try
to understand the rest of it because uh
because I I I don't understand Mr
White's answer
so I don't want to belabor it it's not
seeing none
Senator gray
Senate also asked to have this item
pulled and the word retroactive is the
reason for that the original item you
know through gel car
through gel car on October of 21's whole
thing should have been done by September
of 22 and now here we are many months
later and I know that some of the
testimony you know based on Senate I
mean representative Edwards questions
touched on that I just
since it's a pet peeve of mine I wanted
to let you respond sure so
within the Department of Health and
Human Services we have Financial
directors assigned to each major
division area
within dltss about a year and a half ago
we had a complete overhaul or not
overhaul but we lost our a number of
Staff within that area our financial
director our financial managers as well
one of the individuals had over 20 years
experience as a result of that
we we did not have the the frankly the
the controls in place because much of it
was memory based and all this really is
tied back to the commissioner's road map
where we were looking at Recruitment and
and retention and since that point in
time
the team within dltss has established a
standardized inventory of all the grants
this was a unique situation where
normally we get a formal notice written
formal notice of award from the federal
government this was a odd case where we
did not receive that in the sense that
there was a FAQ a frequently asked
questions that was put out in lieu of a
notice of award I'm not quite sure why
that happened at the federal level
this this is an issue from from my
perspective and it has it has been
resolved I'm also looking at this more
broadly in the sense that I do have many
senior staff
within within finance that will be
retiring in future years and we have
begun some succession planning as well
as further efforts on formally
documenting policies and procedures I'm
a former auditor I'm very big when it
comes to that and I do recognize that
there is a need that will continue to
item number 152 Senator gray moose to
approve
Senator Dallas Andrews seconds any
further discussion
seeing none of you ready for the
question all in favor say aye aye
opposed no the item is adopted the last
uh HS
excuse me HHS item
yeah
recognize Senator Edwards uh thank you
representative Edwards I I'm starting to
thank you uh thank you Mr chair so
um I
I'm just looking for some clarification
on what the most recent thinking is
relative to using uh if you if you look
at a attachment a the very last item
21-100 uh it's uh deals with the 1.1
million that we've already approved to
accept from the federal government long
ago and we've been spending it down and
now there's some indeterminable from my
perspective amount of money that's still
to be spent on this item
it's to be spent on multiple items the
one that catches my eye is the one where
we're going to continue our our previous
state policy of spending Federal money
to provide the coveted vaccine to
children
and I think
given the amount of information that has
come to the four over the last year
about the effectiveness of covid and and
really where that and that injection was
best used I I want to come back and
challenge
a state sanctioned policy that still
wants to make this covet injection
available to otherwise healthy kids I
don't think that's a state something we
want to sanction so so my question is
for that particular subset of that
particular line item
are you able to tell me how much
additional money would be spent to
make the vaccine available to otherwise
healthy kids
that if that that that if we didn't
approve this that money would not go to
that purpose
okay
um just for clarification representative
Edwards can you clarify is this page one
of attachment a or page two and one line
which item number I'll do that it's the
um it's the last item on attachment a
and the item number is listed as 21-100
and and when you read to the right on it
the comments section describes a number
of things for which that money was
previously authorized to spend on
of those things the only one that's
given me heartburn is the part where
we're we're going to continue to spend
money to make the vaccine of I don't
like the word vaccine it's not a vaccine
but um this this coveted shot available
to Healthy Kids
so I I don't have that specific
information available at this point in
time I'd have to go back and dig into
that and work with the public health
Team to get that exact information
um this this requested it mirrors the
fist 23 166 and 167 in a sense of I
understand turning those funds forward
um I don't believe they're at this point
in time if if you if you needed to wait
until you had that information
um I don't believe there would be any
negative impact to tabling I'm not
suggesting that but I'm just putting
that out there because I'm assuming that
may be the next question
so so this I I haven't talked to our
Senate colleagues on this Mr chair
um but I I would like to have us table
item 21-100
only
uh so that we can get some additional
information because I I think it's
important for the state to go back and
revisit the policy the efficacy the
safety of providing this to our children
so our healthy children so so
um
so I'd like to make that motion and
maybe have some discussion because I
don't know where other people are on
this okay so the motion is to adopt the
item with the exception of
21-100
21-100 which which will be tabled
in a second by
representative
further discussions Senator gray
um certainly I think that there's other
vehicles that we can use to express our
opinion to the department I don't see
you holding this up to do that and
certainly I'll vote against the all of
the items on there but I will vote
further discussion I mean I get
clarification on what the senator just
said did did I understand that he would
be open to tabling the whole item but
not just one line item of it no sir I
support the whole thing okay I
misunderstood thank you that there are
other vehicles that we can use to
express our opinion to the department
about how the These funds should be used
and
parents that that want their children
vaccinated we should vaccinate them and
parents that don't want their children
vaccinated we should not vaccinate them
so
that's where I stand
thank you Mr chair I think the
department has and I'm not sure how
they've testified in front of the uh
house Health and Human Services
committee or even
division three but certainly
um because I've asked this repeatedly
in Senate Health and Human Services
there's no move no thought of a move by
the department unless something has
changed in the last month to
um try and add
the covet shot as a mandatory vaccine I
think that's the right policy it should
be
um up to the parents discretion and the
department
to the best of my knowledge and the
commissioner is nodding thank you very
much there's no change in that position
so I'm happy if this policy there are
this fiscal item goes through and should
so so thank you Senators gray and
Bradley I appreciate the wisdom and I
don't really disagree with you I I I I
do not want uh the state of New
Hampshire to be creating an implied
warranty that this is a safe and
efficacious drug for healthy children I
just don't want to be associated with
that policy so uh as as a as a personal
professional matter I'm going to vote
the table this line items just so that
further discussion
the motion before us is to accept
FIS 23155 with the exception of item 21
100 which will be tabled until we have
further information
to divide the question
okay motion to divide
I'd like to take the cabling part first
okay and we'll vote first on whether we
know whether we table 21 100 I'll we'll
do this by a hand you want to do it no
no no no no no do your way all right all
those in favor of tabling 21 100 please
three all those opposed
two three six four five okay that is
defeated
Now we move to acceptance of
FIS
motion by senator
Bradley second by Senator D'Alessandro
we'll do again
okay six opposed
all right now moving on to the other
items that have been removed
the next one we'll address is from the
business and industry 23 146 under tab
6.
good morning Taylor Caswell commissioner
Department of Business and economic
affairs
and someone from the Senate wanted to
had that down request from the Senate to
um my notes don't show any Senate poll
on that one okay uh that it was uh oh I
did have a question
Senator Rosenwald
calling it thank you sorry I'm taking
them out of order okay
um
I'm two questions really how much arpa
funding is still
on
allocated and will this project be
competitively bid or is uh go for
looking at a sole source contract
so first just for clarification I'm on
the left hand side of the table so I'm
Commissioner of ba here when I go over
there I'll be the Gopher okay but that's
just a light way of saying that this is
an item through ba
um so your first question was
um regarding the availability of go for
of arpa funds right so
um
in that regard
we have reached I think a point where
the amount of obligated funds that have
flowed through this committee and
through governor and Council have
reached the extent of the fiscal
Recovery Fund allocation that we had
from the federal government which is 994
million dollars
there are remaining
um funds that continue to be spent by
agencies across state government
uh and there's also a number of requests
that remain in the pipeline of funds to
be used under the fiscal Recovery Fund
so while we have reached the end of the
uh point where we can obligate
additional funds
um that are sort of not have not
previously been obligated
um there will be continue to be a churn
of of funds that are either reallocated
or other situations where we might need
to reallocate before the deadline of
December 2024. okay
was is this contract going to be
competitively bid so as you know we we
um uh we had a competitive process for
the plan that was developed uh that has
led us to this point
um that took a lot less time than we had
anticipated and the robust
the robust level of information and
strategy that has been put into this
effort led us to the conclusion that we
would like to amend the contract that we
are currently operating under to
continue to work with the vendor that
developed the plan
I think there are a number of reasons
for that not the least of which is the
expertise that they bring to the table
and the relationships that we've
developed among nine or ten different
agencies to get us this point but as you
know Senator we're also under a time
constraint with the use of the arpa
funds so we want to be able to continue
the momentum of this project which I
think is very substantial and a
significant investment
to improve the relationship between
state agencies and our business
Community
um all of which was in the item and I
think we did actually send over the the
full report that we had from the vendor
that is over 100 pages long so I don't
expect that you've been through every
bit of that but I think
given the time constraints and given
where we stand in this process our hope
is to amend that contract
represent a Earth for a question thank
you Mr chair and yes thank you for
sending that report that was awesome did
not have a time to read through the
whole thing
um but did have some time to peruse it
and if I could I'd like to just get you
to give some more details specifically
regarding release one first of all it's
a four month Pro period of time
apparently I'd be curious when it when
that starts but more importantly I'd be
curious I've read through kind of the
things that you're expecting there if
maybe you're going a little more depth
in terms of what the expectation would
be of businesses like my own I've done a
lot of stuff through the website over
the last years and it's gotten better
but it's still very hard to find things
and even as a State Rep it's quite hard
to find these I don't mean specifically
your stuff but the website in general
but if you could speak to the the
release one part of this project I'd
really appreciate it sure so
um again I think this is
this potentially represents a pretty
Bellwether change in the way that the
state interfaces with businesses
particularly small and medium-sized
businesses Our Hope with phase one is to
consolidate the resources that are
currently available across all the state
agencies that have a direct relationship
with the business community and right
now that represents nine state agencies
and to be able to bring on new
functionality to the way to the type of
interaction that businesses can can have
with those agencies online
so the first phase really is defined as
what we call minimum viable product and
working with Department of Information
Technology we would be centralizing a
website that would allow businesses to
be able to access permitting
registrations filing licensing and of
various numbers of Support Services
directly online we would drastically
improve the search and navigation
functionality of that under phase one
and we would begin the process of
something that I think it sounds small
but is actually a big deal in my view
which is a checklist for individual
businesses to know what are the things
that you either are required to do or
you have access to or that you are
eligible for that would be
tailored effectively for those
businesses and that first step the
second phase is where it starts to get
really cool because we're going to be
able to have individual identifiers for
businesses so for your business you
would have one identifier that would go
across All State agencies and would
among other things I think really
improve for example our procurement
system so if you're a business in a
certain line of uh in a certain sector
and there are State contracts that are
being offered within that period you
would have notifications when those rfps
are issued so those are the sorts of
functionalities that we're working
towards and and the type of
functionality that we're hoping to be
able to accomplish in a period that is
not going to exceed 18 months is is to
and when would you expect phase one to
start
uh probably as soon as we have all of
our final approvals in place so we'll
come from here and we'll go to Governor
Council on May 31st I believe is the is
their next meeting so at that point
shortly thereafter if is you know as I
mentioned to Senator Rosenwald were able
to continue the relationship with the
vendor we would start immediately
further discussion on the item I'll move
Senator Bradley moves the item
and Senator gray seconds for item
22 150 uh you know 20
23 146. further discussion and let me
note that
representative Griffin is now the fifth
vote on the house side replacing
representative Edwards
all in favor say aye aye opposed no
motion is adopted move lastly to
item 23169
[Music]
a governor's office of emergency is
going to move to C
emergency relief and Recovery
and that was a request by Senator
Rosenwald
that was mine thank you
um
so I
understand that we're getting
uh nine million dollars more of e-wrap
funds
that are federal delegation was able to
secure
am I correct that
we had to return almost 19 million
dollars
of Europe One funds
Sandra good question Chase Hageman
Deputy over at gopher
um yes it's accurate a little less than
19 million was returned under era one uh
this is era2 but also under era1 there
was a reallocation process much like
this one where the state received about
I think between 12 and 15 million
dollars back of basically what had been
clawed back from it and then under this
process this 9 million is being sent to
the state also part of the reallocation
process under era2 so the state had
applied for about 44 million dollars
last October and this is the amount that
was sent to us
thank you so this is going to the half
of it about it's going to the affordable
housing fund is that going to support
only affordable housing and what is the
period of affordability that will be
required so that amount uh yes we would
transfer that to New Hampshire housing
who administers the affordable housing
fund uh all of the funds would be used
in accordance with the rules for their
affordable housing fund which I believe
is an affordability at 50 percent of Ami
or below
for how long
I think I do you know the answer to I
mean I think it's individual based it
depends on the program so they use those
funds in in it for example to to to
subsidize programs under the low income
housing tax credit program or under
other programs that they administer and
those all may have different types of
affordability restrictions and times but
I can say pretty
um with a lot of confidence that all of
the programs that New Hampshire housing
administers have significant time frames
for the affordability requirement and in
in some cases it's 90 years okay thank
you
Senator Roosevelt moves to approve 169
and Senator Bradley seconds for the
discussion seeing none all in favor say
aye aye
first item is 23 170.
Department of Safety eight hundred
Senator Rosen excuse me
Senator dallasandro moves to approve
is there a second Senator Rosenwald
seconds to approve item 23 170. further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
aye aye aye opposed no
that item is adopted next item is under
Office of the governor again
Senator Bradley moves to approve
Senator Dalessandro's seconds on 23-164.
is there any further discussion
seeing none are you ready for the
question all in favor say aye aye
opposed no that item is adopted
twenty three one seven three
under the
judicial Administrative Office of the
Courts
any questions
move to approved
Senator gray moves to prove the item
Senator Senator D'Alessandro seconds is
there any further discussion on 23173
seeing Nani ready for the question all
in favor say aye aye opposed no
under tab 11.
second
uh Senator Bradley moves to approve
Senator Grace seconds to adopt FIS 23156
any further discussion seeing Nani ready
for the question all in favor say aye
aye opposed no that item is adopted
will now recognize the legislative
budget assistant Michael Kane
sure um before we get there
representative there are two late items
uh action items thank you very much
let's move on to the late items sure we
have 23 175 with Department of Health
and Human Services followed by 23 176
which is Fish and Game
Jacob item 23 175 a late item from
Health and Human Services
requesting to extend some earlier
approved
funding any questions on the item yes
I think Mr chair going back to my dad
last time I spoke with you could you
just go into some detail about what this
What's Happening Here
thank you sure
foreign
we are requesting to reallocate arpa
funds that were previously approved for
another purpose the reason that we're
requesting to reallocate these funds
they have approximately four 4. million
dollars is the department
um over the over the past period of time
has been working with Das and an
architect to design the forensic
facility
um that that design was finalized and
the bid was put out by Public Works two
bids came back it's a request for bid so
in that case if they meet the bare
minimum qualifications and they have the
lowest bid then they are awarded the the
winner under under state law and the bit
the bid amount that came back was higher
than what was originally anticipated
um the the commissioner from the
Department administrative Services is
here but as as many of us are are well
aware the the construction industry has
seen year over year cost increases and
that's the reason why it's one of the
key reasons why the bid came in higher
than previously anticipated when this
and where did the funds the four million
dollars come from
sure so
the department previously put an item
forward I believe it was in December of
2021.
um this was a point in time when we were
seeing a significant increase in uh
individuals being admitted to the
hospital
at that time an executive order
2021-12 was issued which directed the
department to take all steps and
measures necessary to try to mitigate
the number of individuals that were in
the hospital open up those beds for
individuals
we had set aside approximately nine
million dollars for ambulatory surgical
centers
to take individuals from the hospital
and to be able to reimburse them for any
potential costs that they would incur
that that weren't covered by third party
insurance or Medicaid the department was
able to
um to move individuals to other facility
types and these funds ended up not being
needed for that purpose and so they were
available and so when we were looking at
the ARP carry four dollars that you saw
on fist 165 and 16667 we identify these
as available
for potentially if with your approval
for the purpose of funding the forensic
facility hospital Construction
one more and when do you expect to start
construction and finish Construction
Lori Weaver interim commissioner HHS
construction once the bid is awarded
we'll start as soon as the bid is
awarded and anticipated timelines there
are a lot of things that need to happen
uh right now we're looking at Finish
starting right away and finishing
sometime around the beginning of early
25.
Senator Rosenwald thank you
um
does the department
have a projection of the operating costs
that we'll see that I guess will occur
during the upcoming biennium
sure so the in the agency request in the
state fiscal for the state fiscal year
26 27 budget you will see our our
request for that
um when we initially looked at the
potential cost there for this prior
budget we were hoping that that the
hospital may be open by that point
um but but it will not be variety of
factors
um we do anticipate somewhere in the
vicinity of 20 million dollars but I
think it's too early to tell
um I think initial if I recall initial
staff estimates were somewhere in the
vicinity of 165 but again it's a 24-hour
facility there may be contracted costs
depending on how how we staff the
facility and what the specific needs are
a year 20 million dollars per year
likely a vast majority of that being
General funds we are investigating other
options to see if there are federal
dollars available to leverage the
department has already started a a
project team on this with a project
manager much of the work for opening
um is is being looked at now what
contracts will we need to go into effect
prior to opening what does the staff
onboarding look like what are the
policies and procedures that we need to
develop in advance and this work is
actively under development and you will
see the requests come through in the
2627 budget just one more Effect one
more I think I heard the commissioner
so don't
will we not need
we will need a budget we will have to
start to recruit if we open at the
beginning of 25 and it has a potential
opening of July 1st of that year we'll
be working to recruit then and looking
at the operating budget for the next the
following biennium explain him
um yes and and and and I believe
um what what we're looking at to the
final construction to be somewhere in in
mid mid 2025 which which would be into
State fiscal year 26 just to clarify yes
Senator Dallas Andrew moves approval on
23 175 is there a second from Senator
gray is there any further discussion on
the item seeing Nani ready for the
question all in favor of approval say
aye aye opposed no that item is adopted
thank you next item late item is one
seven twenty three one seventy six New
Hampshire fishing game
except and expend
522 million 837 federal funds from
American Rescue plan any questions on
yeah
I think it's 522 000.
what did I say 522 000 million excuse me
dealing so much with Millions say that's
outside your department
522 000 thank you for the correction
items been moved and seconded
further discussion I'm sorry who moved
it
Senator dalessandro Senator Rosenwald
so you know I see no further discussion
all in favor say aye aye opposed no the
item is adopted
and
any item any questions on the
information items that the committee
I think now you want to call LBA right
yes now we wish to call legislative
budget assistant Mr Kane yes thank you
very much Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
Michael Kane the legislative budget
assistant for the State of New Hampshire
uh pursuant to fiscal committee rules
prior to filling any position in our
office we do require fiscal committee
approval I would like to request the
approval to fill two performance auditor
positions
um we've been lucky to find two
individuals who have accepted their
offer pending the approval by fiscal to
fill
thank you
second
Senator de Alessandro moves to approve
the hiring and Senator gray seconds
further discussion from the committee
members seeing Nani ready for the
question all in favor say aye aye
opposed no
thank you Mr Kane that is approved thank
you
Senator Rosenberg thank you I do have a
question about
um the
HHS
question
item 23-160 I think it's 160. no
I think it's 160 but
it's information that lbas separately
made available must have come
from the Department
yes sorry Senate it is related to 23 160
uh the department did send Excel
spreadsheets of the information
contained herein but that is the proper
item
foreign
do you have a question from the from the
division I do if they're here
Senator thank you so that it seems like
for the current fiscal year or or like
I'm sorry the biennium
which is ending
um 17 and a half million dollars about
for the Governor's Commission
but what is obligated but not yet spent
is not is almost 10 million dollars
and they're only six weeks left so do
all those bills come in
after the close of the biennium because
these funds thus I understand that are
obligated
contract in an obligated but more than
half of the biennium
spend has not yet been spent
with only six weeks left sure and and I
I apologize just to clarify what
document are you looking at it's it's
not clear to me I believe it's tab 15 of
the spreadsheet you sent us
um
I think it's cynics from a spreadsheet
that the department
sent an Excel form but
yes
there's
LBA put it into a different look no it
looks it looks just like that oh okay
LBA printed it and put it on my desk
that was nice of them very nice so
there's this nice blue line well there
it is very nice blue line
and I'm looking at the top third where
the governor's commission had 17.6
million dollars
for the biennium but what's contracted
but still unspent
as we're almost at the end is just under
10 million
sure so
um
the way that
where to start so the governor's
commission uh the funding appropriated
to them is continually appropriated and
non-lapsing
if we have a contract that's encumbered
um those those funds would carry forward
into the next biennium if they weren't
spent
um so when when we enter into a contract
we may enter that you know six months
into the year something on loans those
lines maybe a year it could be a two or
three year contract there could also be
amendments associated with these
contracts
um June the to governor and executive
Council meetings in June we typically
send through several hundred uh
amendments and contracts during that
period of time
um we we do about 800 Amendment
contracts annually typically the May
June months are when you do see a
significant amount of volume occur at
GNC and and so while this may show up
like this what will happen in the next
several weeks will probably produce a
very different result than what you're
looking at there
thanks could could we just ask that you
share the updated result with us
sure for in in state fiscal year 24 so
for the July meeting
which is when you would see the
difference
that's just an informational item so we
don't need a motion on it
so we come down to the date and time of
the next meeting for the fiscal
committee uh there's been a suggestion
because of conflicts on on the 16th
likely
is that is that a problem with any of
your schedules uh I had the UNH Board of
Trustees that day so that's a whole day
thing it's the morning thing
it looks like Health and Human Services
oversight
also is that morning
I missed that because of this so yeah I
that's the beginning of the COC week
the following the earlier Friday is the
beginning of the committee of
conferences
I mean I think anything while we're
potentially committees I think we've had
two okay so starting at one o'clock on
okay
could we not doing in the morning one
o'clock
oh but that's all day right well usually
on the Friday they end for noon time
1pm on the 23rd all right that'll be the
all right
anybody second
all in favor say aye aye aye we are